Let's start thinking about repairing systems
and not just putting a bandaid on it.
You have diabetes, drug number one,
then you escalate to drug number two,
then you get cardiovascular disease
and you add two more drugs there, right?
So everybody is going along with the system
and nobody wants to change it.
(air whooshing)
(gentle music)
We know that nutrition can revolutionize
almost everything in medicine.
It's not gonna cure everybody,
but it can certainly make an incredible difference
more than we've ever seen.
Hey, everybody, welcome to the podcast.
Today, we're gonna talk about the science of fasting,
the science of nutrition, longevity,
and disease prevention with Dr. Valter Longo.
One of the world's leading researchers in this field
returning for his second appearance on the show.
Named one of the 50 most influential people in healthcare
by Time magazine in 2018.
Dr. Longo is a professor of Gerontology
and Biological Sciences
at the University of Southern California.
He's also the director of the Longevity Institute at USC,
as well as the director of the longevity and cancer program
at the IFOM Institute in Milan, Italy.
In addition,
Valter is the author of the international bestseller,
"The Longevity Diet"
all profits of which he donates to research
and to his foundation.
And he's the creator of something called
the fasting mimicking diet.
Today we pick up where we left off four years ago,
episode 367, if you missed it,
covering the latest research on fasting
and the five nutrition pillars of longevity.
We discuss various fasting strategies,
the acute versus chronic effects of food on metabolism.
We talk about optimal protein intake based on age
high fat versus low fat diets.
How to think about and contextualize other protocols
emerging from healthspan science and technology,
and many other topics.
I love geeking out with Valter.
He really is one of the world's brightest minds
on the cutting edge of longevity science.
And this one is full of prescriptive advice,
including how to separate
what we know from overblown hype.
So if this channel is providing you value at all,
all I ask in return is that you take a moment
to click that subscribe button.
Thank you very much.
And with that, I give you Dr. Valter Longo.
Valter, it's great to see you.
It was awesome to reconnect with you in Miami recently.
I'm glad that I did not give you COVID.
It's been four years since we did this
and, after seeing you,
I thought it would be great to have you back on,
and there's so many things I think that we could talk about.
There's been a lot of research in science
since four years ago, but I thought a good place,
an interesting place to start
would be with this recent study that just came out
this study that was published in the New England
Journal of Medicine.
A study coming out of China
that showed that intermittent fasting had no impact
versus regular feeding windows in terms of weight loss.
Now, I know your expertise is in longevity
and not weight loss
but because this study was sort of widely covered
in the media and caused a little bit of a kerfuffle
amongst fasting enthusiasts, in the kind of wellness world
in general, I assume you're familiar with this study
and I thought it would be wise
to kind of solicit your thoughts on it.
Yes.
So, my understanding of the study
was that they looked at long term calorie restriction
plus or minus of time restricted eating.
So either you're calorie restricted, severely,
and then you eat within window of eight hours, I believe
or you're just calorie restricted.
So first of all, it's really a pointless study
because this long term calorie restriction studies,
we already know that they're gonna result
in people regaining their weight back.
They're too excessive and also most people don't realize
that they're probably associated with this thrifty mode,
meaning that the body eventually slows down metabolism.
We know this from multiple calorie restriction studies
and so now you're stuck
and there was an old New England Journal of Medicine study
showing that, so now you lose weight,
but now your metabolism adjusts even lower
than your adjustment per kilogram body weight.
So that means that you're pretty much condemned
to regaining all the weight
and so it's a pointless study to begin with.
And then in addition to that,
you add the time restricted eating.
I don't think it's a valid argument.
I'm not a big fan of 16 hours a day.
I'm a big fan of 12 hours of fasting a day.
But I don't think it should be used against the 16 hours
because it was just a study that shouldn't have,
I don't think it should be done, not that way
and it doesn't really lead to any conclusions.
Right, I mean, what was interesting about it
first of all, it was conducted over a period of a year.
So at least according to the media,
that was the longest term under which they had studied
humans with some kind of setup like this,
but the feeding window was 8:00 AM to 4:00 PM,
which I guess, it's sort of like eating an early dinner.
It's not that different than a normal feeding window.
Yes, but again,
you are associating it with severe calorie restriction.
It was 1,500 calories, 1,800 or something like that.
Right, for males is severe calorie restriction
even worse than all the people did in the past.
So these are already starting with something
that is so extreme there, and at the end of the study
you can see that what we know happens in most cases,
they start regaining weight.
So, starting the eight or nine months,
you start seeing the weight regain, which is, again,
what's been observed in so many studies.
Right, they also identified no substantive difference
in risk factors, which of course is related to longevity.
But in your mind,
is that a function of the calorie restriction?
Or why was that part of the results as well?
Well, I mean, if you go from 2,500, 3,000 calories a day
to 1,500 or whatever.
Yeah, it is not surprising that in addition
compacting it into eight hours versus however many hours,
it makes no difference.
So I don't think that says anything about fasting
in general.
Fasting, first of all is not 16 hours every day.
Fasting is a lot of different techniques,
some of them work and some don't
and that one happened to.
I think it told us
that if you're already severely restricted
eating within eight hours, doesn't help you any further.
Right.
So we're gonna define these different fasting modalities,
what works, what doesn't in your opinion
and how we're thinking about longevity
but before we do that,
if you were to construct a proper study,
what parameters would you set up?
Like, what did they get wrong?
And how could somebody do this,
where it would show legitimate, effective results
that would be reliable.
Yeah, well, first of all,
you don't wanna do severe interventions like that
because people will abandon it.
And then when they abandon it for a few times,
it's worse than when you never started.
So it's better to let somebody be overweight and even obese
than take them to these yoyo cycles
of losing a lot of weight, regaining a lot of weight.
So we know that from previous studies.
So yeah, I have two foundation clinics
and we try to minimize the changes
and try to be as effective as possible with minimal changes.
And you wanna probably take a couple of years to get there.
So we have diabetes patients
and people with cardiovascular disease
takes a couple of years to convert somebody back
really convert 'em into something that they can sustain
for the rest of their lives.
So you wanna intervene, for example, the longevity diet,
which I just published an article
describing why the longevity diet should be adopted.
It's a high carbohydrate, but not high refined carbohydrate
and not a low sugar, low refined carbohydrate,
high carbohydrate composed of lots of legumes,
lots of whole grains, nuts, et cetera.
So that's the type of diet.
Of course, each person
is gonna have a different version of it, right?
So if you're gluten sensitive,
you're probably not gonna have a whole grain
high carbohydrate diet,
but you can pick a different type of high carbohydrate.
So, by just the protein restriction,
we now know to be regulating weight.
So, most people, lots of people eat a lot of proteins
to lose weight
and it turns out, based on our research
and research on many others to be the opposite.
The protein restriction is leading the system
to go into a fat catabolism, a fat burning mode
so this is just one trick.
Another trick is eat a lot.
So if you eat legumes, it may take a pound of legumes
to get 45 grams of proteins.
If you eat a steak, it takes 200 grams so a lot less.
So I think there's lots of tricks to get somebody
in short term, lose weight, particular abdominal fat,
without losing a lean body mass.
We just finished a study
where we are looking at Mediterranean diet
and after four months, on the Mediterranean diet
patients lost three pounds of muscle mass.
Sorry, yeah, three pounds and after seven months,
five pounds of lean body mass.
So, I think there is a whole system to be adopted.
And as you know, I believe in this periodic fasting diets
that can get you to slowly lose weight
without losing lean body mass
and again, in a couple of years,
by the combination of the everyday longevity diet,
which I just described and the fasting diet,
I think that most people that adhere to it
are gonna mostly lose fat, but also,
undergo some type of reset,
going after insulin resistance going after
maybe some inflammatory issues, certainly some cholesterol,
high cholesterol, et cetera.
So you mentioned this article that recently came out.
I assume you're talking about the article in Cell
that you coauthored with Rosalyn Anderson.
Yes.
So explain that.
I thought that was really interesting.
It basically establishes the parameters
for this longevity diet and why it's so effective.
So maybe explain what the longevity diet is
and what this article kind of explored in terms of the link
between nutrients, fasting, genes and longevity, et cetera.
Yes.
So the longevity diet tries to move away from an opinion
and move into a multi-pillar system.
How dare you?
Yeah, exactly.
So, for sure the epidemiological studies,
lots of epidemiological studies,
so studies of big populations,
and then the clinical studies,
the centenarian studies and lots of focus,
at least in that paper that you just mentioned
on model systems.
So what happens in mice and what are the genes
that control aging and what are the nutrients
that control the gene that control the aging process.
So, that on one side you have the obesity
and all the problems that come with it.
On the other side,
you have the acceleration of the aging process itself.
And we always think about smoking
and obesity as major risk factor for diseases
but when you compare 'em to aging,
they disappear as risk factors.
So targeting aging is the most important thing,
even more than obesity, way more than obesity.
So if you can slow down just a little bit,
the aging process, you can do much more than obesity does.
Of course, obesity and smoking are a big second and third,
but they are dwarfed compared to the aging process.
Right, so you began your career looking at yeast
aging in yeast to try to identify what these mechanisms are.
Maybe explain how this is applicable to human health
and what exactly, like how we should think about
what that aging mechanism or process is.
Yes.
So actually I started with Roy Walford
working on humans and mice,
and I understood that it wasn't going anywhere.
So I went back to yeast from humans and mice
which at the time people thought it was a just bad idea,
and so I think that if you look at the genes
that regulate aging in many organisms, and we think humans
because now we've been following people
with a certain mutation, which I'll talk about in a second.
The growth pathways seem to be at the center
of the aging process.
So if you take a yeast, a fly, a mouse,
and now we'll talk about humans, they live a lot longer
if you block IGF-1 insulin and other growth factors.
And not only, they become a lot longer lived
so yeast, for example, by blocking this protein pathway
and then on the other side,
blocking the sugar pathway and then starving them.
They live 10 times longer.
So you completely reprogram their ability, their lifespan.
And this is compressed as you move up.
So in mice, they live about 40 to 50% longer
if they have deficiency in these growth genes,
particularly the growth hormone gene
and the growth hormone receptor gene.
And so when we then study humans,
those deficient in the same gene growth hormone receptor,
we haven't proven yet longevity extension,
but they're protected from cancer.
They're protected from cognitive decline,
they're protected from diabetes.
So they seem to be protected from most of the human
chronic age related disorders.
So we suspect that we are also gonna see lifespan extension.
We're not gonna see 50% like in mice,
but even if we saw 10%, 15%
with very little chronic diseases, that would be,
I think, remarkable.
How do we understand the nature of that compression
as we go from yeast all the way up to humans
and why it doesn't scale in a more linear fashion?
Probably because of evolutionary theories,
meaning that every organism
has evolved by being able to have different modality.
So for example, yeast, you can have a modality
it's a life in the fast lane
and they live about two or three days.
Then you can starve them a little bit
or starve them, and they live about two weeks.
And then you have something called the spore state
and in the spore state, they live 100 times longer
than in the fast lane, so they live years.
So that tells you that probably in every organism,
there's like a reproductive grow mode.
And then there is a maintenance mode
where the decision is made
that there's probably not enough food,
not enough to grow, not enough to reproduce
so I'm just gonna stand by
and try to protect myself as best as I can.
So now of course,
most of us are now reproducing most of the time.
So probably a good idea, right?
To switch to that modality and stay there
until we are ready to reproduce.
Right.
Okay, so then with respect to humans,
you've identified these five pillars of longevity.
So maybe we can walk through them
and then drill down more specifically on the diet piece.
Yes.
So, in this study, you just mentioned,
epidemiology, of course, is very central so lots of studies,
epidemiological studies looking at,
what people that live long eat.
And so one thing we published on a few years ago
was if you look at Americans,
those that have a high protein diet,
they do very poorly compared to those
that have a very low protein diet,
but that's only true up to age 65.
And then after 65, it turns around a little bit,
and those that have a moderate protein intake
do better than those that have a low protein intake.
And I think if you look at the data
and you look at the Harvard studies,
they're supportive of this.
So they will say that a low carbohydrate diet
is bad for you in general, unless it's a plant based
low carbohydrate diet.
They haven't looked so much at the age, dependent effect
but I think we are in agreement that low carbohydrate diet
and high protein are not good for you.
It should be the other way around
low protein and high carbohydrate.
And so epidemiological studies are, I think,
generally consistent with this notion.
So for example, there's another, Lancet meta-analysis,
looking at carbohydrate intake,
and it's better for lifespan to be an 80% carbohydrate diet
than to be in a low carbohydrate diet.
And if you go to very low carbohydrate diet, I say 20%,
there's a 60% increased risk of mortality
compared to the 50, 60% of the calories
coming from carbohydrate.
But then what happens is the people confuse this
with excess carbohydrate.
They think that when I say high carbohydrate diet,
I mean excess carbohydrate.
So we had doctors for example, complain and say,
well, now we are in United States,
70% of people are overweight and obese,
and you're talking about high carbohydrate diet
but in fact, I'm talking about proportions.
So you gotta get food from somewhere,
of course, you have to have the right amount of calories.
You cannot have excess,
but about 50 to 60% should probably come from carbohydrate.
Yeah, so epidemiology shows that
and just to give you an example.
If you think about carbohydrate,
if you look even in a yeast or a mouse,
if you feed 'em a lot of sugar, in most of the cases
you're gonna accelerate some of the aging pathways
on the sugar side, and then even more clearly
on the protein side, but especially on the amino acid
certain amino acid, like methionine
seems to be at the very center
of the acceleration of the aging process.
And this is pillar too.
So basic research and then clinical studies,
I think are pillar three.
They're very supportive of all of this.
And so, for example, in the longevity diet,
we talk about fats, yes but certain type of fats.
And if you look at, for example,
the work by Astoruk in Spain,
thousands of people randomized one group at risk
for cardiovascular disease,
one group placed on a low fat diet
and one group placed on lots of olive oil or lots of nuts.
There was a study that came out like just last week
about that, I think.
There's been many studies followed up.
Maybe there was one last week, I didn't see that one,
but now it's pretty consistent in showing that,
the high olive oil, high nut diet is better for people.
Right which is so interesting
and somewhat counterintuitive
with respect to cardiovascular disease.
Yes, historically and to this day,
lots of prominent experts will say, go to a no fat diet,
no matter what it is.
So sure, it seems to be true.
It's better to not have saturated fats, animal fats
and again, the epidemiology agrees with that
but when we are talking about these monosaturated fats,
olive oil, nuts, probably certain fish like salmon,
that seems to be consistently associated with living longer.
And then, the centenarian studies of course,
one of the most important pillars.
So if a low carbohydrate diet is not so good for you,
let's look around, let's look at Okinawans
let's look at people in Sardinia, in Calabria,
in Loma Linda, in Costa Rica, in Greece,
do they have a low carbohydrate diet or do they have,
as we will expect a high carbohydrate diet in all of them,
a very high carbohydrate diet,
including the Okinawans.
Who used to get about 70% of their calories
from sweet potatoes, as you heard at the conference
from them.
Right, so with all of that,
and of course, it's about
when you're talking about a high carbohydrate diet,
you have to drill down on what that means specifically.
It's not eating pretzels and tons of refined carbohydrates.
These are like whole plant foods for the most part.
Yes. I mean, it can also be whole grains.
So whole grains in this study done by this Norwegian,
this meta-analysis came out a couple of months ago,
by this Norwegian group.
The number one source of food
associated with life expectancy increase was legumes
and number two was whole grain cereals.
So, it's not just, let's say vegetables,
but it's also lots of carbohydrate that may not necessarily
be associated with health.
For example, say whole grain pasta,
but even pasta, it's probably okay.
Certainly it was okay for most of the centenarian
in most areas.
And so, for example, for the Okinawans, the sweet potato.
You wouldn't necessarily think that sweet potato
is that good for you, but it was very good for them
and so I think you cannot for sure have lots of bread
and lots of potatoes and lots of pasta,
but a certain amount of it is probably not bad.
And don't forget that our body
is not fueled by complex carbohydrates
eventually it's fueled by sugar.
So eventually gets turned into pure sugar
and that's what the brain and every other cell wants,
unless you have ketone bodies or fatty acids around.
So yeah, sometimes we forget the basic biochemistry,
but we are fueled by sugar.
So with this understanding,
the kind of basic tenets of what comprises a diet
that promotes longevity based on this research,
where does fasting come in?
What is the relationship between these dietary pillars
and these protocols around fasting or fasting mimicking?
So I think there are two,
I always look first at the safety factor.
So what is it that we don't know if it's safe or not?
And then I just exclude them until we have many decades,
I think of evidence.
But if you look at safety and efficacy, both,
I think you come up with 12 hours every day
as being very solid.
I always say, I've never seen a study
showing that if you do 12 hours of fasting a day,
you are gonna have a problem.
When you get to 16 and as we,
I think already discussed before
you get to 16 hours, you get to breakfast skipping,
I see meta-analysis, not just studies,
but studies of all studies showing increased mortality,
reduced life span.
Now, what is the reason for it?
We don't know, probably there are double edged swords.
So for example, ketone bodies, maybe fatty acids,
ketone bodies are going both ways.
They're helping you on one side and they're hurting you
on the other side, but so 12 hours, very solid.
And they work by Satchin Panda
and everything else is supportive of it.
And then I would say probably people we eat all the time.
And so, thousands of years ago, as humans evolved,
we evolved probably insulin resistance as a way
to survive the winters.
So, you eat as much as you can during the summer,
or whenever food is available,
you become diabetic essentially, prediabetic or diabetic,
you put everything away.
And then the winter comes or some period
where there is no food
and then you become insulin sensitive again.
So I think what happens now
is everybody is insulin resistant all the time
or somewhat insulin resistant all the time
because the winter never comes.
And that's where this prolonged,
not just 16 hours of fasting, but say five days,
that's what we've been working on, that's where they come in
seems to be pretty clear.
Now we have three more clinical trials
that we are about to publish.
Very clear that they switch you
into an insulin sensitive mode.
So, and also, they switch you into a long term
antiaging mode.
So for example, leptin,
and this is about four clinical trials that we've done.
Leptin stays low for a long time
after you return to a normal diet.
IGF-1, the central growth factor proaging
stays down for months.
So, in the first trial, we showed that after three months
from the end, IGF-1 was still lowered.
Yeah, so then I think that there is a one side
insulin sensitization.
So the system now goes into a fat utilization mode
versus building.
And the system also goes into a maintenance mode.
So now I'm just gonna protect myself as much as possible
ages slowly as possible,
waiting for the next wave of lots of food
where maybe I can focus on reproducing.
Right, so with this understanding that there is no winter,
the winter is not coming
and everybody's kind of hurtling towards some degree
of being prediabetic because of the Western way of eating.
How malleable is that?
Like, if somebody has been in that prediabetic state
or in a situation where they lack insulin sensitivity
for a prolonged period of time,
what is your sense of how one can repair that?
Like, obviously, if you've just arrived in that situation,
it's probably gonna be easier for you through fasting
and these other protocols to bounce back
and create some insulin sensitivity
but if you've been in that state for a decade,
does it become more difficult or can you still repair it?
You can still repair it.
We just finished like a trial on diabetes in Holland,
100 patients, and I cannot tell you the results,
but I could tell you that even if you're diabetic,
you're obese, you've been taking medicine for years
and years and years.
No problem, we can bring it back.
We cannot bring it back in everybody,
but I would say the great majority of people,
you have the team, the physician, the dietician,
and you have to have the method.
And in that trial, it was just fasting mimicking diet
no longevity diet.
In the clinic, we do both.
But again, we don't push you to 1,500 calories
if you had 2,500 calories.
We push you to keep the calories,
maybe just a little bit lower
and maybe go from 2,500 to 2,300.
And then we work on the nutrient tech,
what I call nutrient technology.
We work on making it easier for you to lose weight
rather than starving you for a year,
hoping that you stay like that for the rest of your life,
which you're never gonna do.
So in the four years, since we sat down,
there's been quite an explosion of interest in fasting.
It's gone from this, kind of curious endeavor
into something that has truly gotten mainstream attention.
Lot of discussion about different ways of fasting
and many different, as you mentioned,
different types of thinking about fasting,
intermittent fasting, alternate day fasting,
time restricted eating, fasting mimicking,
maybe it would be worth kind of just talking about fasting
in general and the validity of these various protocols
and why you feel so strongly that the fasting mimicking
approach is optimal.
Yes, so alternate day fasting,
it's an extension of the 16 hours, let's say, right?
So there is no doubt that if you do
16 hours of fasting every day,
or you don't eat every other day,
you're gonna get a lot of metabolic effects.
The problem, and the question is
now that we have meta-analysis,
showing that if you skip breakfast, you live shorter
and you have more cardiovascular disease
and probably more cancer, et cetera.
Is there some issue with these ketone bodies,
with these fatty acids, et cetera, et cetera.
So no arguing with the metabolic effects, short term,
but a big problem with long term, right?
So I would say, don't do it, certainly don't skip breakfast.
Now we are starting a trial in is
now what happens potentially if you skip lunch,
so keep the 12 hours and then skip lunch.
That's what I've been doing for 20 years
but now we're gonna finally get to test it.
We don't know but let's see.
And so that's alternate day fasting, or let's say 16/8.
Then you have, let's say 5/2.
That's another popular one.
Well, what happens if you do two days a week of fasting
or semi fasting?
Well, we don't know because there is not very many studies.
There is a few, it looks promising.
The problem I see with that is
most people have a difficult time I say,
going from four coffees a day or three coffees a day
to two coffees a day,
half of the people that used to smoke are still smoking
even though we know that it kills you
and it says that on the package.
So is that gonna really be more than a small percentage
of the population.
So even if we show that was effective, who's gonna do that?
I don't know, personally,
I don't know anybody that will go two days a week
without eating anything.
I don't know a single person,
but that doesn't mean it could not be effective
and that doesn't mean there are not people
that could do it long term.
So I'm not arguing that, with the effectiveness
and I'm not arguing that some people could do it.
I will say the great majority of people are not gonna do it.
And then I will say, we even don't know
what will happen long term.
So we gotta go with things that are more realistic,
less invasive
and that's where the fasting mimicking diet comes in.
And this is again, 30 years of work
since the Walford years.
So it's not an idea that I say,
oh, I see a few patients in my clinic.
They're doing so well with this five days
I'm just gonna do that
as it happen for many very popular diets in the past.
So this was 30 years of building,
building from all these pillars.
And then you get to a point, where you say,
this looks very promising.
What if we made people do this three times a year
for five days, four times maybe.
And if you have diabetes, in the diabetes trial,
we did one cycle a month for 12 months
but most people did not do 12 cycles.
Some people did two, some people did six.
Some people did eight and some people did 12.
So now we're gonna analyze the data
and we'll be able to tell who is doing well, but overall,
they all did well.
So, I think that that two to four times a year, let's say
some people might even last
somebody like you probably, couple of times a year,
it'd be more than sufficient.
But for most people, I say three to four times a year,
that seems to be very realistic.
It's clearly showing this long term efficacy.
It allows for FDA like, it doesn't have to be FDA,
but FDA like procedures where you can say,
Hey, this was tested.
That's exactly the way you should test it
and everybody can test it. Everybody can grab it.
So now we have 30 clinical trials running.
Some of them, we help 'em with, some of them,
people just get it and they do their own trial.
So that's the way you should be, allow everybody to test it
and let's see.
Eventually, we're gonna see these are millions of people
and we still gonna see the reports from it
and I really think that that's slowly moving in the toolkit
of physicians on one side for lots of diseases,
but it's also moving in the toolkit of the people
that are paying attention
and that want something that has been clinically tested.
And just because we haven't defined it,
essentially, what you're saying
is this is a five day protocol where we provide you
through prolong this meal delivery meal kit situation.
And when you eat this way,
you're mimicking your biological response to fasting
without being overly calorically deprived.
Yeah, I cannot talk about products,
because I'm prohibited from doing it.
So in the FMD, for example, for cancer, it's four days,
it's very different from the one for normal people,
which is five days, as you just mentioned,
then we have one for auto immunities it's seven days.
We have one for Alzheimer. We are testing now in Italy,
which is five days,
but then it has a daily supplement in between.
So it's really about nutrient technology
but yes, the fasting mimicking diet
let's say goes from four to seven days in most cases,
plus, or minus what could be supplements.
For example, in the Alzheimer,
we were worried about people losing weight
and some people did lose weight.
And so that's why we give them a supplement
between the 25 days between one cycle
and the next of the fasting mimicking diet.
We also, because they're so old,
let's say 75, 80, 85 years old,
we give them a higher calorie fasting mimicking diet.
So, yeah, we adjust based on the age, on the disease
and eventually I think there might be adjustments also,
for example, now we're developing a non-inflammatory one now
also people with inflammatory bowel disease, colitis,
gastrointestinal problems,
we're developing something that is non-allergenic
non-inflammatory, which I think is gonna be very important
and we, I mean the university,
I'm not talking about a company.
So yeah, I think that's certainly,
I'll be very surprised if this doesn't move
into more of a mainstream
and start competing with the drugs
that's what we're trying to say.
Let's start thinking about repairing systems,
based on all the things that we discussed
and not just putting a bandaid on it.
You have diabetes, drug number one,
then you escalate to drug number two,
then you get cardiovascular disease
and you have two more drugs there and this is what happens
and it's really criminal, I think.
In the United States, in Europe all over the world
I call it unconspired conspiracy.
So everybody is going along with the system
and you have a lot of bad food
and a lot of drugs that people take and the whole system
is profiting from it but people, the average 45 year old,
now has got two chronic conditions in the United States.
And so by the time you get to 55-60,
you probably have about three chronic conditions
taking lots of drugs, right?
So we were saying,
what is this system not to just block that,
but to bring you back to a healthy status.
And it used to be ideas
now we see it in the clinical trials,
but we also see it in the foundation clinics
where we follow lots of people.
So we're very confident that this can work,
but it's not gonna work unless
the team that I was discussing earlier,
the doctor, the dietician and the knowledge,
and probably also the molecular biologists.
When you get too complex,
so we get people at the clinic all the time
and they have very complicated problems.
And so you have a very busy physician even around
and you have a very busy dietician.
And I think that the molecular biologist
specialized in whatever field, it could be the key person.
So the strategies, like I am.
So this person comes in, works with the physician
and works with the dietician to strategize,
how do I solve the problem?
This person's got three chronic conditions,
where do they come from?
And how do I solve them without creating another problem?
That's gotta be at the very center of everything
and it's not.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome
but I wanna snag a moment
to talk to you about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire
to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans, and legumes
into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools and support
very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly
and because I want everybody
to experience some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised,
I'm proud to say is The Plantpower Meal Planner.
Our affordable all in one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious, and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery,
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches,
seven days a week, and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up,
visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life changing stuff people for just $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com, promo code RRHEALTH
for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
Well, what's interesting about all of this
is understanding the incredible resilience
of the human body.
Like it can be abused for extended periods of time,
and when you course correct that,
it's kind of amazing that the body is able to get back
to some sort of homeostasis
without a pharmaceutical intervention.
The trick of course, as you mentioned,
is getting the medical establishment to truly grok this
and make it part of what is recommended in their protocols.
So what is your sense of where you're at
with that right now?
Do you have doctors who are on, I'm sure you do
that are prescribing this, that are on board with it,
and what is the resistance or the obstacles
that you still face?
I mean, obviously the gold standard
would be getting it to be reimbursed by insurance
and that kind of thing.
I assume you're not quite there yet.
There are, I don't know,
maybe 30 or 40,000 doctors around the world
that are now just recommending fasting mimicking diets.
And I think they're all saying more clinical data,
more FDA style clinical data and absolutely.
So then we and others and most of the studies
we are not doing, Universities are doing it on their own.
We're just helping them, so, yeah.
So I think that everybody's waiting for more studies,
they're coming.
Lots of them are already finished
and we're about to publish 'em.
But I think, for cancer, Alzheimer, autoimmune disease,
et cetera, we are gonna see more and more.
But I think in addition to the FMD,
I've been talking to lots of politicians,
both in Italy and here, and I'm saying,
imagine you have over 70% of people that are overweight,
that are obese with all the chronic conditions
that we discussed.
And I said, imagine if you say,
well, people are uneducated in that country,
but I'm not gonna have schools
and I'm not gonna have teachers,
but I want everybody to be educated.
It's never gonna happen.
You can say it as much as you want,
but until you build the schools
until you have the teachers, it's not gonna happen.
So here we know that nutrition can revolutionize,
almost everything in medicine.
It's not gonna cure everybody,
but it could certainly make an incredible difference
more than we've ever seen.
So certainly anything that is obesity related
and overweight related.
But we need to have the schools
and we need to have the teachers.
But these are gonna be schools and teachers of nutrition
and lifestyle and I think that that's by far
the number one thing we're missing.
Then I think, if you can get that,
as we shown it in a mouse study that we recently did,
which you may have seen before, so we say, okay, forget it.
It's never gonna work.
So let the mice eat lots of fat and lots of calories
and become huge and then once a month
we give the FMD, the fasting mimicking diet
and we reverse everything.
So, I'm sort of going against that.
I think people should be followed
and should be professional.
So you don't get into very bad diet every day
and then use the FMD to fix it
but I think that's the idea of the FMD,
maybe for those that are now willing to make daily changes.
That's where you bring in the food as medicine.
Right, it's such a massive problem
because every force that surrounds us
is driving us towards that unhealthy choice
everywhere we turn, all the marketing,
the way the stores are configured, et cetera.
You're almost bucking the trend in order to eat healthy
and considered an outlier.
So education certainly is central to all of that,
but there's also a social piece and a psychological piece.
And as Dan Butner talks about creating infrastructure
or environments that are conducive to the healthy choice,
because like smoking that has the label on it that says,
it's gonna kill you
a lot of people just want to eat what they want to eat
'cause it tastes good.
And until they suffer from some kind of chronic ailment,
they're really not gonna look in the mirror and redress it.
Yes, and I think you can probably even get closer.
So you have to have like the teacher in the school,
you have to show up at eight o'clock
and then you have to stay there until such a time
so yeah, no, I don't mean that for people,
but I mean, let's say for example,
once a month you have a telemedicine call on the computer
with your dietician and your molecular biologist.
And maybe once every six months with the physician,
that's not very invasive
but now with all the apps and devices,
you can monitor their weight from the distance.
They wouldn't have to tell you what they're weighing.
You can monitor the blood pressure.
You can monitor lots of different things
and now pretty soon the glucose level,
you're gonna be able to monitor without even using a needle.
Yeah, so I think we're already at a point
and that's what we're doing in Italy, by the way,
we're starting this 500 people clinical trial with control,
fasting mimicking diet, longevity diet,
plus the fasting mimicking diet.
So hopefully in about a year and a half,
we'll have solid data showing I hope success but yeah.
So it's not school eight to one,
it's one telemedicine call once a month.
And just to make sure that you're on track,
you have any questions, and for example,
with the cancer trial, we see that when we do that,
it's very successful, very high compliance.
We do fasting mimicking diet and chemotherapy, et cetera.
The only trial when we didn't do that,
we allow the clinics to just say,
oh, here's the fasting mimicking diet.
You take it home and do it.
Then we went to 30% compliance.
So most people could not comply for more than maybe 50%
for two cycles of the fasting mimicking diet
with chemotherapy, and then it dropped down.
So it just told us that, yeah.
And hopefully at some point it'd be also good
to have a psychologist involved, as you mentioned.
So this team of four people,
I think physician, psychologist,
molecular biologists, dietician
it should be our schools and our teachers for lifestyle
and we don't have it.
Yeah.
Well, I think that some of these new apps and technologies
can really help with compliance as well.
Like I started working with inside tracker and levels,
the continuous glucose monitor
and there's something about being able to pull the app up
and look at where you're at in real time.
That makes it very, kind of maybe not urgent,
but you're just connected to it in a way
that's very different from going to your doctor once a year
and getting your blood work done
and seeing what it looks like on a piece of paper.
So how are you thinking about some of those technologies?
Like, do you think there's a place
for continuous glucose monitors
with respect to kind of the avenues
to which you're trying to push your patients
or the people that you're working with?
Yeah, the technology of course is gonna be central,
but I think the human part, we cannot underestimate it
even if it happens by telemedicine
and the psychological part.
So lots of things would love to be done,
the old style, but yes, as new technology comes in
and the ones that we're talking about,
whether it's the scale connected directly to the network
or the continuous glucose monitor, et cetera, et cetera,
those are gonna make everything easier.
But I think that now we're starting
to start a program in South Central
you are a very highly educated lawyer, right?
So most people are not as educated as you and I are.
So I think that we need to also create a reality
for people that may not have access to this world,
this very tech, high tech world.
And so, yeah, so we're starting a program in South Central
and there, if it gets funded,
we're gonna try getting to the houses
and try to convert slowly again,
take a couple of years maybe longer.
And can we convert this family, the children,
but also to the parents into this changed lifestyle
and I think it's gonna take a lot of,
I don't think we just gonna be able to say,
oh, I sent you an email with an application attached to it.
I'll see you in a year.
I think for the great majority of the people in the world,
for a number of years, we're still gonna need to be present.
And the physician is definitely too busy and not trained
for any of this, by the way.
So then yeah, we need to have this team
but the applications will certainly,
and eventually artificial intelligence
and the collection of, let's say microbia data,
metabolomic data, et cetera. It's gonna take a while
but at some point, you get maybe a drop of blood
and you'll be able to say,
I don't know why, but you have a problem with iron intake.
So Leroy Hood and other people are working on this.
And so I think that, but it's gonna be maybe five, 10 years
down the road.
So now I think having 70% overweight group
or obese group here,
and 50% overweight and obese in Europe, we need to act now.
And then once the technology comes,
I think that's even better.
Yeah, well you can't solve the problem
without understanding how to solve the problem
in underserved communities like South Central,
because that's really where the problem rests
and those communities
they're not going on PubMed and reading research.
There's gonna have to be a completely different approach
to try to figure out how to penetrate those communities
and create real change.
Yeah, and that's the extreme,
but I think there is a middle group.
All over the United States
that is not in that conditions,
maybe as a lot of people in South Central,
but is still gonna be much harder to penetrate
than the Los Angeles or San Francisco or New York,
highly educated individual that follows everything we do.
So I think the majority of people live
in a very different world than some of us and I think that,
but the majority of people will appreciate
if you get a call from a dietician and a psychologist
or this team once a month,
I think the majority of people will respond very well.
We certainly see it with the sick people.
Whether they have cancer or diabetes,
that sort of feeling like we're following them
and we're, okay, you got a problem.
Here's a team you got,
you got a team following you and helping you
so I think psychologically in addition to everything else
is essential.
One of the things I'm curious about,
and this sort of came to me in the process of experimenting
with a continuous glucose monitor
is that you get this real time data after you eat
and you can see, the kind of curve in the graph
of where your blood sugar is at postprandial,
but I'm wondering, me as a consumer and not a scientist,
I can look at that and I can draw conclusions from that,
but I'm not sure those are the best conclusions
because what's happening postprandial, post meal
is probably different from how it should be looked at
from like a chronic perspective.
So when you're thinking about, or conceiving of
what should go into the fasting mimicking diet,
or just a healthy diet in general, on a daily basis,
how do you think about what's happening
biologically with each meal versus the chronic conditions
that are the result of eating a certain way
over a very long, extended period of time?
Yeah, so we get all the time, people,
they may do something
that contain the fasting mimicking diet and say
my glucose spiked
your glucose should spike, if there is glucose
or some form of carbohydrate in the diet
and in the fasting mimicking diet,
we put the carbohydrates on purpose.
It's a lot less than you will have in a normal diet,
but it's still there.
And it was designed on purpose
to make sure that we don't have this yoyo
that I was talking about before.
Why do I know that this yoyo let's say,
we went much lower in carbohydrates.
Let's say we went to zero carbohydrate, 10%.
I don't know that it will hurt people
to go back and forth like that, but I'm worried that it may
and I'm also worried that it might affect muscle.
So now we have three clinical trials showing no muscle loss
and increasing absolutely relative lean body mass
and that's very important. So now we believe that sugar,
I mean, not sugar, but the little bit of carbohydrate
they have in there.
And even though they come with a little spike
on glucose,
we believe that to be protective of the muscle mass.
And so now, eventually we're gonna look at
more lower glucose versions to see what happens,
both for compliance and for muscle mass, et cetera,
but right now I think we feel pretty good
about having all these great results
from clinical trials that that's irrelevant.
And not just the fasting mimicking diet,
it doesn't really matter.
Even in the everyday diet,
you don't worry so much about your glucose monitor
and whether there is a spike, worry about the consequences,
an abdominal circumference, body fat, insulin resistance.
So if you're A1C, HB-A1C is 6.5, you got a problem.
If you have a spike in glucose and your A1C is 4.7,
you're fine. It means that your glucose goes up,
your body can process it.
I wouldn't do 20 meals like that a day.
I would stick with, let's say two plus one
or three meals a day and that's it.
So you only have three opportunities for that to happen,
and that's perfectly fine.
And that's obviously not affecting your body
in a negative way.
Yeah, so it's very important to, glycemic index fine,
but don't become obsessed with things
that are part of a much more complicated network,
including that may help you protect lean body mass.
So we now know that TOR can be affected
well, we knew from our work in yeast, 30 years ago,
but we knew that both sugars and amino acids
could feed into TOR and so now they're starting to
be data looking at say, leucine levels,
being essential for muscle building,
but the glucose might also be pushing that leucine,
the amino acids to perform more.
These are still preliminary data,
but certainly now that's a possibility
that if you go too low in sugars,
the muscle might struggle in building
as long as you're insulin sensitive.
Let's go to protein for a minute.
You mentioned earlier,
the idea that you've arrived at that lower protein
before age 65 is optimal and then after 65,
it's important to increase your protein intake.
So maybe walk me through how you arrived at that conclusion
and what that means specifically
for somebody who's listening or watching.
Yeah, so if you look at the mouse studies,
for the past 50 years, low protein is one of the ways
that you can substitute calorie restriction
to extend the life of a mouse.
Then I think we did our study that mentioned earlier
clearly showing that the low protein group
had overall lower mortality
and the high protein group had a 400% increased risk
for cancer mortality compared to the low protein.
Now, keep in mind that low protein
doesn't mean you're not eating protein.
It means that you have to have the 0.35 grams
per pound of body weight. So if you weigh 100 pounds,
you should have at least 35, 40 grams of proteins.
If you go below that,
now you're starting it into malnourishment.
So it's low protein without malnourishment.
Right, correct me if I'm wrong,
about half of what the FDA would recommend.
Isn't it 0.8 grams per kilogram?
Kilogram, I was talking about pounds.
Okay.
Yeah, no, no.
So 0.8 is fine.
So we are staying with the American Medical Association,
I think say's about 0.8.
So that RDA, but in terms of like how most,
at least Westerners eat that would be considered
low protein, even though that's like,
kind of exactly what we're supposed to eat.
Yeah, so the average American will have maybe
50 to 100% more than that.
And so, 0.8 is perfectly fine per kilogram
but then it should be mostly plant based.
And I think our study, all the Harvard study,
the Jovani Franco, et cetera, they agree with that.
And the centenarian and the Okinawans adds
9% calories from protein levels.
The Southern Italians,
certainly mostly plant-based, the Loma Linda people,
low protein.
It is pretty clear.
It's pretty consistent, pretty consistent,
no matter where you look
and now the clinical data is also supportive of that
potentially causing weight loss
and the opposite way everybody thinks.
So having a low protein high, the right carbohydrate diet
can lead to weight loss instead of weight gain.
And that we love to wait and have bigger studies,
but that's what it's looking like
we are gonna see happening.
And is that related to a reduction in mTOR activation
and IGF-1 levels?
Or what is it specifically about
the protein biomechanically that's happening?
It looks like certain amino acids
are controlling the fat cells
and they're controlling the hypothalamus
and they're really in charge of the decision
to accumulate fat or breakdown fat.
So what I was talking about before,
about the fasting mimicking diet, it looks like
and so we are actually now submitting a large grant
to study that in the brain.
It looks like the certain amino acids are at least in charge
of maybe health of those effects.
So telling the body, okay, now I'm gonna start burning fat,
or now I'm gonna get into a fat accumulation mode.
And yeah, so some of these switches
are probably long lasting.
So maybe epigenetic, may not be epigenetic.
So epigenetic meaning that the DNA is getting modified
and so once it's modified,
this could last a long, long time,
but there's certainly long lasting.
And this is why after the fasting mimicking diet,
which of course is very low in protein.
We see the leptin down for a long period in people
and we see the IGF-1 down for a long period.
So yeah, so we don't quite know
the answer to your question,
but I think it's looking like reprogramming
it's got a reprogramming effect on multiple systems.
And so what is happening around age 65,
where that flips and it becomes more important
to increase your protein intake.
Yeah, so if you look at the in hands,
which is the CDC database in the United States,
and you look at the weight.
So most people and most people don't notice
most people, on average people gain weight until 65,
and then they start losing weight after 65.
So it's something that we don't know what it is,
but aging of course, is at the very center of that.
And there may be some key moment of the aging process
where you are now getting into this rapid aging modality
and we know that because most of the deaths occur after 65.
So yeah, so after that,
and this is also the Samsung group did in Australia
did this in mice. So after a certain age,
it may be that the redundancy so that the system
needs more of the amino acid to do its minimal job.
And if you don't,
if you started having deficiency, you have a problem.
And in our own study, we did that with mice,
we took young mice and we gave them a very low protein diet
nothing happened.
We took all mice and we give them the same,
very low protein diet
and within days they started losing a lot of weight.
So it's probably a matter of redundancy
and maybe some of these growth factors are involved
and once you get below a certain threshold,
you have a problem
and you may have a problem in the immune system.
You may have problems with bones, with muscle.
You may have a problem in the cognitive system.
So yeah, so I think it is just unsustainable
for an older organism.
Well, it would seem that
the more you're on top of these healthy practices
as you inch towards 65 and after 65,
the better position you're in
to prevent those sort of declines being as rapid
as they would otherwise.
So if you're maintaining your muscle mass
with resistance training, if you're eating appropriately
in accordance with your protocols
and the sort of blue zones criteria,
and you're engaged in your community
and you have purpose in your life
that a lot of that like extension or prolonging of longevity
is really about the robustness that you enter
that stage of life with
so that it doesn't hit you like a ton of bricks
and you kind of become decrepit in an expedited way.
It's a equilibrium of robustness
because on one side,
you could be feeding your muscle with IGF-1
and there's no doubt about it.
And on one side you could be feeding the cancer cell
with IGF-1.
And so as you enter that stage.
But if you're doing the plant-based protein.
Well, if you're doing the plant-based protein.
If you increase your plant-based protein.
You're gonna become frail
as most of the Southern Europeans like the Italians.
Don't tell me that Valter.
Yeah, so we cannot mix the doing it right with doing it.
So the Southern Italians are actually twice as frail
as the Northern Europeans,
or the Italians are twice as frail.
At a certain stage in life or later in life,
they become more frail?
They're long lived, but frail,
that doesn't mean that you cannot be vegan or pescatarian
and be very strong,
and that's what we've been working both in Italy and here
very hard with mice. We said, what is the nutrition,
the age specific nutrition that prevents a frailty
to the bones, to the muscle, the immune system
but at the same time
does not affect the longevity extension.
It's very tricky.
There's a sweet spot in between those two polarities.
And there is an age dependent, sweet spot.
That's why we're saying now don't go from low protein
to high protein, go from low protein to moderate
maintain the plant based, but start introducing more
let's say vegetarian, if you don't want to have,
a meat component, a vegetarian component, more eggs,
more cheeses, et cetera.
Now of course you can do it without any of this
you can do it with seeds and nuts.
You could be 100% vegan and do it.
It's just a little bit more of a job to do it
while staying vegan but that's perfectly fine.
Right, but when you're 100, what else do you have to do?
You could divert some of that energy
towards being focused on that.
It is not just energy, you gotta have the people.
Some people that know what they're doing.
For example, the legumes are very low in leucine, methionine
et cetera, but the seeds are not,
and the nuts are not.
So yeah, you need to pay attention
and have somebody help you, guide you through it
because otherwise you can become osteoporotic
and not realizing it at all until you have a fracture
and then you're in trouble.
Yeah, I had a guy in here who is 100
and he broke all these marathon records
when he was 90 and 91 and just an amazing guy
but he went plant based at 70
in response to a colon cancer diagnosis
and has been plant based for 30 years
and at age 100, he's as passionate about it as ever.
And he still is running and training
and doing all of these things.
And so when you're saying that,
I understand everything you're saying,
and I see this living example of a guy
who appears to be doing it correctly
and was telling me he's having the most fun
he's ever had in his life so it's crazy.
I mean, keep in mind, a lot of people that are vegan
eat a lot of proteins.
So a lot of vegan proteins.
I'm sure he's eating a lot more protein.
So yeah, if you eat a lot of protein, let's say 25%
and this is very common among vegans.
And, so for example, I think Luigi Fontana did a study
where he was looking at the vegans
and their IGF-1 was actually pretty high,
because they were high protein,
they had such a high protein diet.
So even if you're eating a ton of plant-based protein,
you can still drive up IGF-1.
Yes, absolutely.
Because we're talking about 10% and below in our study,
10% of the calories or less had to come from proteins
to be in the low protein group.
So if you're now 25% of your calories coming from protein,
you're most likely are gonna be in the high risk.
And in fact, in our study, we did
the people that had mostly planted-based
instead of a fourfold increase in cancer risk.
They had a threefold increase in cancer mortality risk.
So it changed, better.
Went from 400% to 300% increase risk of cancer mortality.
Prophets walk among us.
As a writer and podcaster for nearly 10 years,
I've become more convinced than ever
that our world is populated by scores of beautiful
and brilliant people who have amazing stories to share
those that we don't know who can teach us something new
and leave us all the better for the experience
of their sharing.
And so I've dedicated my career to tracking down
the most compelling prophets on the planet,
going deep with each of them on my podcast
to elucidate the best of what they have to offer
and to sharing the insights gleaned for the benefit of all.
But the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories,
which is why I'm proud to announce
the release of my new book, Voicing Change, Volume two.
More than mere words on paper,
voicing change is a physical manifestation of the magic,
inspiration and timeless wisdom that transpires each week
on the Rich Roll podcast.
The first edition of Voicing Change
was a beautifully rendered book worthy of display
on any coffee table and Volume two follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite conversations
in an elegant publication replete with interview excerpts,
essays, and stunning photography,
making for an exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying standalone work.
Picking up this book allows you to revisit the wisdom
of your favorite everyday prophets
and physically interact with the life changing ideas
contained with them.
Voicing Change, Volume two available now
while supplies last for a limited time.
Order your copy today only at richroll.com.
I'm interested in your thoughts on another,
like the other side of the coin
with respect to healthspan science and longevity,
because a lot of the press is oriented around this,
the sexiness of things like rapamycin and Metformin
and sirtuins and the like,
which is very different than the kind of longevity science
that you're interested in and focused on.
So how are you thinking about what's going on
in that kind of related field
with respect to looking towards extending healthspan?
Yes, so first of all, I come from that world.
So I come from the world, we were testing rapamycin in yeast
and I think we got it from Michael back in 1995 or that.
So we were probably the first lab in the world
that was working out rapamycin and longevity.
And my lab discovered the role of the TOR pathway
in aging in 2001.
So we are very much supportive of the understanding
of what genes and what drugs the affect genes do
but I think that for the next 10, 20 years, maybe 30 years
reality is that we have 3 billion years
of what I call, 3 billion years of R and D.
So our body has been developing for 3 billion years
if you think about the origin of species.
And, so you could say,
I'm gonna bio-hack my way through it.
So I have this incredibly sophisticated system
and I'm gonna intervene with a drug that blocks TOR,
but TOR, that's so many things.
And guess what, if you block TOR in people with rapamycin,
they become hypoglycemic and mice become hypoglycemic.
So it's just very clear evidence
that it's not as straightforward.
All these downstream.
You have to look at it holistically
and understand there's a bazillion intervening variables,
and it's all very complicated.
It's very complicated and you have no data.
So who knows what happens after 40 years
of rapamycin or Metformin?
I mean, Metformin's got more data.
So in support of Farxiga is trying to do,
Metformin's got a lot more data, but even Metformin,
what happens if you give it to somebody
that's perfectly healthy?
Well, we don't know.
And I think that's gonna be an issue.
And also, but if you look at statistics
or if you do some calculations,
the easiest success is gonna come from something
that is already existing for that purpose.
So if you are a yeast and I already know
that I can switch you into a modality
where you live five times or 10 times longer,
because you've evolved that modality to sustain moments
where you don't have enough to reproduce,
then that's by far the safest,
because it's there for a purpose.
So then the question is,
is there a human alternative modality
that is much longer lived and everything points to yes.
So otherwise we wouldn't see these little people in Ecuador
not getting any disease.
We have one guy that we just interviewed
and he's 80 years old
and he's been drinking and smoking every day of his life.
And everybody else does not have a disease,
but we thought this guy, there's no way.
And sure enough, never had any chronic condition
and is drunk all the time, smoking all the time.
So having the mouse data and having the human data now
and all the other organism,
we know that there is alternative mode.
So if you're gonna intervene with drugs,
my opinion is that intervene in the master regulator
don't intervene downstream.
So intervene very high up,
let's say the level of growth hormone,
releasing hormone growth hormone, et cetera,
because that's more likely to not interfere with anything
intracellularly and not come up with as many problems
as solutions.
Right.
So I assume that would be the same perspective
with respect to supplementation.
You hear about NR and NAD and all of these kind of protocols
that people are adopting in the kind of bio-hacking world.
Do you see any efficacy or validity
in playing around with that or what do you think?
Playing around with the research, yes
but I think that when you have,
this is why we go multi pillar.
You have to have the epidemiological studies,
the clinical studies, the centennials,
how many centennials have been taking this
for 70 or 80 years,
and what is the research on all these different organisms
saying?
So I think the closest you get to four or five pillars
supporting it and the more you can think about it,
but it's hard to imagine any of this,
having that kind of support thus far.
So yes, you could say,
take 16 hours of fasting.
Again, there's no doubt that that's very beneficial,
but then you gotta wait 30 or 40 years.
And then you get the meta-analysis
and people that skip breakfast, have a problem.
So you would never have known that
until you get to that point,
those famous studies of all studies.
So, then the question is for all these supplements
and interventions, where is the data competing?
Let's say with what we already know can get you
to 100, to 110 now.
So I think now we're starting.
If you look at the study in Norway,
the life expectancy increase, if you started
it's about a third of what I described
in the longevity diet, it was associated
if you started at 20, with 11 to 13 years
of life expectancy increase.
If you started at 60,
was associated with eight to nine years
of life expectancy increase.
So now you add the fasting mimicking diet, 12 hours a day,
three times as much.
Now you're thinking 15, 20 years, not thinking
the data would suggest maybe 15 to 20 years
of life expectancy increase.
So you introduce a supplement.
What if that decrease your lifespan by 20 years
after you take it for 30 years?
Right, we don't know yet.
Yeah, you have to make sure.
We're not in Las Vegas and this is people's lives,
so you wanna take a chance like that on your life,
much better to go with what we know than what we think,
is gonna happen.
My sense from looking at your work
is that what's good for longevity
also appears to be good for cancer risk reduction.
Is there a point at which those two diverge,
because you are focused in these two worlds.
So what's similar about them seems to be a lot,
but is there anything dissimilar
or something that somebody who is suffering from cancer
or concerned about
that should be doing a little bit differently
from somebody who's purely focused on longevity?
The only concern is of course,
the frailty and the cachexia, et cetera,
when you're a cancer patient.
And this is a big fight we have in every clinical trial,
in many places around the world.
So the physicians will say,
I'm not gonna allow you to put this extreme vegan
or close to vegan diet
in between fasting mimicking diet cycles.
And we fight to get it in there because we're saying,
treat cancer first and get the cancer
and if the patient is losing some muscle mass, that's okay
compared to, let's say a very rapidly advancing cancer.
So, yeah, but it's a legitimate concern.
And so we've been collaborating with Alexandro Laviano
at the University of Rome, who's an expert in this
and trying to get to the point.
And in fact, in the clinical trial that we published
last year, we were successful in doing that.
So the women that had breast cancer
and received hormone therapy with the fasting mimicking diet
we dozed the in between diet in a way
that allowed them to maintain a very good lean body mass.
So muscle mass.
Yeah, I noticed on your website,
you have different kind of protocols or marching orders
for different types of people with respect to FMD.
So you have protocols for people
who are undergoing chemotherapy
or about to undergo chemotherapy
for pregnant women, for adolescents, et cetera.
So how do those protocols like shift and morph
depending upon your stage of life or whatever it is
that you're kind of going through?
Yeah, I'm not sure which website you're referring to.
I can't remember.
Or maybe it was the other one.
I mean, obviously for diseases,
we tell people, talk to your physician,
and together with your physician, decide whether,
this should be applied.
And then, in most cases we like to have a clinical trial
rather than improvisation, but yeah,
it's a discussion with your physician.
And then for everybody else,
again, different people, different situations,
some people are gonna need the dietician to work with.
Some people are gonna need the physician to work with.
Some people don't need anybody
if it's just trying to lose some weight
and maybe again, a little bit of reset,
but I think that, as I was saying earlier,
the team is not there. Maybe it's not all necessary,
but certainly a dietician that knows what they're doing
should be consulted before starting.
So we do this at the foundation.
It's a nonprofit clinic and in Santa Monica
and we have one in Italy
and so we'd be happy to help anybody there
even those that cannot pay at all.
So we have a program for those that cannot afford
even the visit.
So I think it's good to figure out what you need.
So, yeah.
What is the ideal period of life to begin this process?
Like if you're a teenager,
can you see benefits doing an FMD?
What is your sense of what the science says
in terms of younger people?
Yeah, well, so we started a clinical trial
in Gaslini Children's Hospital for type one diabetics
at age 10 to 18.
And we've been talking to CHLA
Children's Hospital of Los Angeles,
about one for obesity and overweight control.
So we don't know,
and this should only be tested as a clinical trial
in fact in Gaslini Hospital. They're gonna be inpatient.
So nobody wanted to take a chance with the children
and allow them to do it outside
but yeah, I think that it may turn out
and I don't know, but we'll test it,
we'll test it for the possibility that
this five days of a vegan diet
will allow the physical improvement in the child,
but also a psychological improvement.
So it's an exposure to five days of a vegan diet
with certain characteristics,
which may be very different from what they eat all the time
at school and at home.
And so that's our hope,
is able to reprogram the child
psychologically and physically so that they eat better.
We clearly see this in adults.
So yeah, some of the effect, the IGF-1, et cetera
is not psychological,
but some of the effect we think is psychological
meaning that many of the adults
are changing their relationship with food
and they don't feel,
they're not appreciating some of the bad food
as much as they did before.
In science, we have something called food aversion.
So some foods are associated with problems
and you stay away from it
because they cause some other problems,
but then there would be also,
probably there is also the opposite of food aversion.
You feel so good with this vegan five days,
fasting mimicking diet that your brain might be telling you
let's move in that direction 'cause I don't know why,
but I felt better in those five days.
And maybe in the few days following.
So yeah, so I think that the child,
my speculation is that the best moment to do it
would probably be, let's say in a teenager
because that could really change your life.
So we know that I wrote a book about children and longevity,
and we know that if you're overweight continuously
from age seven to age 18, you have a fourfold increase
in the risk of developing diabetes.
So intervening in that, at that age,
could have even a bigger impact.
Right, as you're forming those dietary habits,
that will become more calcified with age.
Habits, but also potentially epigenetic changes.
So we know that for example,
you can do a methionine restriction or a protein restriction
in the mouse, early in life and stop and they live longer.
It's really remarkable.
Is there a connection to the microbiome with that?
I would assume there is some gut microbiome changes
that take place that take route.
It could be affected by the microbiome,
but it could be the entire,
the brain and maybe cells in the brain
and the adipose sites, the fat cells,
everything is now reprogrammed into,
okay, let's accumulate fat
for potentially the rest of our lives
and this is why some people,
we see people that have been, say overweight for 20,
30 years and you were asking me earlier.
It takes a long effort to convert 'em
their brain is completely set into,
I have to get back to that weight
because probably it makes sense.
So if you've been okay for 20 or 30 years
at a certain weight, even though that is overweight,
your brain is trying to bring you back
and knows that you're stable at that weight.
And so trying to move it to another weight,
it's a challenge.
And so, yeah, so the child potentially could be condemned
for the rest of its life of his, or her life
to be at this overweight status,
which evolution set to protect them
and not to hurt them.
Right.
And there's something metabolically that happens
that creates like a set point
that becomes very difficult to permanently alter.
Like, you can go on a diet, you can gain weight,
you can lose weight,
but ultimately you're gonna always settle back to that,
that one place.
Yes and that's why I was saying,
that's probably like the steady state
that your brain recognizes as safe
because everything was working when you were there,
like your reproductive system and everything else
was working.
So I know if I get you back there,
let's say that you were 140 pounds,
a woman that is overweight 140 pounds.
And the system, if you've been there for 25 years,
the system knows that you're doing okay at 140 pounds.
And so once you get back there
also, because of what we were saying earlier,
of course it wants the reserves to be there.
The fat accumulation is part of survival
so you used to die if in those two months of no food,
you did not have that extra 10 pounds or 20 pounds of fat.
So there is more than you were healthy at 140.
There is also, I don't wanna take any chances.
Let's keep that fat.
So we stigmatize obesity and yet obesity
and even diabetes potentially
is part of our survival mechanisms.
So that's why it's so important to, instead of no,
now we're talking about, oh, you cannot say,
every weight is good for you.
I think we need to move into, first of all,
don't stigmatize it because it's part of who we are
and part of, with the emperor penguin,
and so many animals have an obesity state periodically,
So it's perfectly fine to be obese,
but it's not perfectly healthy to be obese all the time.
And in fact,
it's better to be at a normal weight all the time.
So, instead of stigmatizing, let's remove that,
but let's also try to help people make it
to a weight where they can be happier and healthier.
Is there a sense of the mechanism
that's creating that set point,
because if you could really understand that
perhaps you could figure out a way of changing it.
So metabolically you create a new sort of,
steady state for that individual that would be healthier
than whatever it is that they're currently settled on.
Yeah, I think we're getting pretty close
with the molecular mechanism.
So, for example, in mice,
when we take the mice on a high fat, high calorie diet,
and then we give them the FMD, the fasting mimicking diet,
and then we look later, four days later,
and 15 days later, they're still breaking down fat.
And leptin is down
and so the whole system is now being rewired.
Now, I think it's just a matter of details,
but we have a pretty good handle
on what controls these different states
either put that away or break it down and it makes sense.
You enter the winter state and at some point
you fast for long enough and that's your switch
and so it's your switch.
Start breaking it down and continue to break it down
but then as I was saying earlier, you fast for too long,
and now it's your thrifty mode. So now your system says,
okay, now I'm gonna starve if I keep using fat
at this level.
So I'm gonna slow down my metabolism
and I'm gonna try to burn the fat more slowly.
And that's why you need to have the science to get you.
Yeah, do the fasting mimicking diet, but don't go too long.
Don't go too short 'cause you don't enter
this catabolic mode.
Don't go too long because now you're gonna enter
the thrifty mode.
You have to thread the needle.
You have to convert the switch
and then allow it to be in the high metabolic
fat burning mode.
And for example, that carbohydrate
that we include in the fasting mimicking diet,
it could also be helping that.
We don't know all the details of the molecular switches,
but it could be that one of them is very low carbohydrate,
zero carbohydrate.
This could be one of the triggers of thrifty mode.
Okay, so now I am going into a very low metabolic mode
because I don't wanna risk running out of fuel.
What is the role of exercise in all of this?
It would seem that if you're vigorously exercising,
obviously you're gonna eat more food.
I don't know what the relationship between exercise is
and metabolic health, but when you're burning more calories,
maybe that changes the way that your body
is dealing with all of this.
Like how does that all play into longevity?
Yeah, so it shouldn't be about calorie levels.
It should be about the results of that.
So if you're losing muscle mass
then you probably need to eat more.
So there is not a set level of calorie they should take on
and you probably should eat more proteins,
so different people, different sports,
different training regimen and different nutrition.
And of course you need to try to stay as close as possible
to the longevity diet but for some people,
that might be too extreme to maintain
whatever muscle mass or the ability to train that they have.
And so they have to tweak it so that you can do
what you think is so important to you.
And so get the longevity benefits and don't compromise
what's essential for your sport.
Well, I guess I'm thinking more in the context
of how exercise fits into longevity more broadly,
because when you look at the blue zones communities,
these people are not going to the gym and doing anything
that's all that extreme.
They're just living kind of consistently engaged,
active lifestyles.
When you look at the way we think about exercise
in the Western world, it is going to the gym,
putting muscle mass on,
or it's being an endurance athlete and going out
and doing very long stuff.
It seems that there would be sort of a middle ground
where this is helpful in terms of life extension,
but past a certain point, you're harming yourself
or you're undermining your body's ability to persist.
Yes, so as I was saying earlier,
lots of people in the blue zones are frail.
It's okay, it doesn't kill you because they live long
but they're frail.
And some of the people that might have record longevity
probably have genetic predisposition to it,
it's pretty clear.
I took a lot of trips in Italy
and interviewing hundreds of centenarians and I hear a lot,
my sister made it to 95 and my brother made it to 92.
And when you see that, there's a big genetic component.
That Loma Linda maybe
that seems to be a unique case study.
But Loma Linda does not have many centenarians.
Loma Linda has longevity extension,
worker Gary Frazier and others,
but not necessarily lots of centenarians.
So, yeah.
So I think that when you look at the meta-analysis
for exercise, 150 minutes of exercise per week,
seem to be ideal as you go to 300 minutes,
you don't get any benefits.
So now you wanna probably keep to around 150
and learning from the blue zone and the centenarians
I would say an hour of walking a day,
maybe a couple hours of walking during the weekend.
That seems to be a good compromise and also weight training.
Yes, they didn't do it, but again.
To combat the thing.
I see 'em all the time, they're pretty frail.
So of course they were not frail when they were working
in the field and doing manual labor
but when they stopped, then they become very frail.
So I think that's why it's so important
to keep the weight training, very light,
for example, in a cancer patient, we have a video now,
we utilized and there was 20 minutes a day
of a very light muscle exercise.
So just enough protein,
light muscle exercise training
and then 150 minutes a week, which is not that much.
And then one hour a day of walking
and maybe a couple of hours during the weekend,
that seems to be pretty solid,
no matter how you look at it,
whether the centenarians and the blue zone people were right
or whether the meta-analysis are correct.
But I think that's why you wanna get the common denominator.
Let's just get in the middle of all of it
and does this violate anybody's rule?
No, it doesn't.
So I don't think a centenarian will say 150 minutes
a little bit more of strenuous exercise is gonna hurt you.
And, again, lots of them, like the shepherds,
they used to do, five, 10, 15 miles a day
going up and down the hills.
They might not be exercised the way we view it,
but pretty close.
Yeah, pretty close.
And even the women that stayed home
in Sewulo Villa Grand residing
when we interviewed them, they said
my husband used to go, and walk with the sheeps,
but I would be in the field as I was a farmer.
And it's a lot of energy that goes into farming.
So yeah, I would say they probably did
a good portion of exercise like activities.
So walk me through your daily routine with food
and exercise. What do you do and practice?
Yeah, in breakfast,
I have this almond, almost 100% almond and cocoa spread
very low sugar.
And then I have what's called a friselle.
I get 'em both from Southern Italy.
It's a whole grain toast, but it's very particular.
And then, in the United States in the six months
that I'm in the US, my lunch is-
Oh sorry and then I have an apple and tea.
That's my breakfast every morning.
No coffee.
Coffee is my lunch.
So that's all I have for lunch is coffee
in the United States.
In Italy, I can't skip lunch.
So I have lunch also in Italy.
And then if my weight is under control,
then at five,
I will have another friselle and maybe another fruit.
If my weight tends up,
then I skip the snack at 5:00 PM.
And then my typical dinner would be,
let's say about 70 grams of pasta,
about 350 grams of legumes, beans, chickpeas, et cetera.
And then about 300 grams of mixed vegetables,
like green beans, et cetera.
So a pretty big dish, lots of olive oil
and usually like a little piece of bread
so of course, then I have fish maybe two times a week
and that's about it.
So that would break down.
It feels like somewhere around 70% carbohydrate, 20%.
No, maybe.
Maybe 50, 60% carbohydrate 'cause I have lots of nuts
olive oil.
Yeah, so those are of course more calories per gram.
Yeah, so I would say probably about 60, 30, 10 to 13,
14% proteins.
And when you're in Italy, more pasta.
No, not necessarily.
More big, long lunches.
But lunch and of course, and then I gain weight
a little bit, not very much,
but I gain weight by doing these three plus one,
three meals plus a snack.
And so, yeah.
So now we're gonna test my lifestyle on 500 people
It's randomized, let's see what happens.
And all your blood markers are good and fine?
No drugs.
Of course, I come from a family of hypertension
and all kinds of problems.
So thus far, I've never taken a drug.
Everything is in place.
Yeah.
And how old are you now?
54.
Not a gray hair on your head.
Now I have.
A little bit,
and how often do you do the FMD then for yourself?
I do the FMD maybe couple of times a year,
but I'm pretty strict with the rest.
So, I think that in the trials we see that,
I mean, the ones that are like the examples of health,
they're not benefiting at least acutely
as much as the normal people let's say.
Yeah, so I think that I'm already
probably because of the longevity diet every day
and the 12 hours, I do that.
So I do 12 to 13 hours of fasting per day.
And so, yeah.
And then the lunch keeping,
so I have a double sort of daily fast.
So I do the nightly fast,
but I also do at least a partial daily fast.
So I think that probably twice a year is good enough.
Yeah, you mentioned that you have a study coming out soon.
Where is your focus clinically at the moment
and what are you looking to kind of explore
in terms of your research?
Moving it to standard of care is my ambition
for anything that is cardio metabolic.
So diabetes, prediabetes, metabolic syndrome,
I think we are getting very close too
have the conclusive studies
and this is not gonna be conclusive, but certainly
these three or four that we're publishing now
are gonna move in that direction
where I think most people say, okay, I believe this.
And then we're gonna need, in some cases,
talking to the FDA, in some cases, maybe not,
maybe have programs that are more lifestyle centered
in support of the standard of care.
But I think the FDA is now starting to understand,
appreciate more that they have to allow.
So this lifestyle intervention to go after the diseases,
because of the obvious, very bad state we're in,
with almost 20% of the GDP going to healthcare.
So cardio metabolic, and then slowly moving,
I mean, metabolic and then slowly moving to cardiac,
prevention and potentially treatment
and then of course cancer.
So lots of trials are going on for cancer
and we are excited now, we just went to the FDA,
filed an IND and now we got sort of the, okay to proceed
with the FDA process for a food as a drug
for hormone therapy.
So in combination with the hormone therapy
for women with breast cancer.
So that's great because we thought maybe the FDA
is gonna be opposed to this, but I think they were very,
they seem to be very supportive and that's cool.
So that's good news
and I think, the more the merrier
I encourage every university that want to do studies
we'll help 'em, we'll give 'em the FMD
and they can tell us their results.
So I'm very enthusiastic about Alzheimer
because of course of the brain rewiring that occurs.
Now we have data from mice,
but let's say this is really changing
the way the brain functions for five days.
And so we like this idea that maybe that's what's needed
for Alzheimer's, so many drugs that failed.
And so maybe a complete reset of the brain in some ways
that it may help, it's kind gonna be a miracle,
but certainly if it help people,
people don't realize if we postponed aging by five years,
we will cut Alzheimer's cases by half.
Wow.
So all we need to get rid of almost half
of Alzheimer's cases is to slow down the aging process
five years.
That's why I think that,
Del Brads and another now are talking about,
the ability to detect 20, 30 years before.
So now if you're 50 and you can tell that 80
you're gonna have Alzheimer,
then that's a great time to switch to longevity diet
plus FMD.
And we'd be shocked if we don't give you
the extra five years.
But as I mentioned earlier, now we have data,
not just our own, looking at 15 to 20 years
of life expectancy.
So, yeah.
So I think that's some of the enthusiasm for what we do.
Yeah.
Well, I think with the advent of scanning technology
and the ability to early detect some of these things
is gonna be a huge thing as well
because if you know, early on,
this is where you're headed and you have these tools
that you're developing at the consumer's disposal to deploy,
to prevent them from getting that.
I mean, it's massive.
Yes, and especially now,
because I think that a lot of physicians
were trained in this world,
where there was cardiovascular disease or diabetes
or Alzheimer, there's nothing you can do about it.
That's it, you're stuck with diabetes,
which is shocking that anybody will say that
but that's been the story for a long, long time.
Now I think everybody,
including the physicians that are starting to say,
well, maybe not
like maybe now we could do something about it.
That's when then you wanna know,
you wanna know that you're insulin resistant,
or you wanna know that your calcium score is very high
and you're at risk of having a heart attack,
et cetera, et cetera.
So, yeah, because now you have interventions,
especially in nutritional that can revolutionize
or certainly have a big, big effect on the risk.
And so, yeah, good to know.
I mean, it's massively important,
heart disease being America's number one killer,
the explosion of rates of type two diabetes,
Alzheimer rates also escalating alarmingly.
Like this is where our focus needs to be at dealing with
these are the three big conditions
that are plaguing the most people.
Yeah and don't forget that diabetes almost doubles
the chance of Alzheimer.
So we already know that a big factor in Alzheimer
is the metabolic dysfunction.
So if it doubles that now,
if you can intervene and now you have 70,
72% of people overweight or obese
and 10% of the population being diabetic, et cetera.
Yeah, this is just shocking,
shocking there is not a government center, big effort.
And we are now presenting some of the calculations,
like how much you will save
if you had the team that I'm talking about.
Every dollar you spend, you get 10 back or five to 10 back.
But then you get it back just with the diabetes.
That's the incredible thing.
So if for every dollar you spend in this team of dietician,
molecular biologist, physician, psychologist,
you get feedback just for diabetes.
Then the rest of it is bonus
the Alzheimer, the cardiovascular disease, the cancer.
So I don't have an explanation other than
the unconspired conspiracy,
there's just too many people that are making money
the way it is, and nobody wants to change it.
And so the media is confusing the hell out of everybody.
And people they say, I don't know what to do
every day, low carb, high carb, high protein, low protein.
Now they're gonna listen to me and say, oh, low protein.
Now this is a new thing.
So yeah, we are moving away from facts
and moving into fashion.
And this is very convenient for people
that are making lots of money the way the system is,
because then if it's confused, you don't change it.
Right, yeah.
From the tobacco industry, confusion is our product.
As long as consumers are confused,
they'll continue to purchase our thing
and remain in the dark.
And this is much harder because now food,
I just mentioned pasta, bread.
So if you eat the right amount, it's perfectly fine.
And when you go to an excess, if you have like in Italy,
everybody was blaming sugary drinks for the overweight.
So the Italians are now at the same level of overweight
as the Americans and everybody was blaming junk food
and the sugary drinks. When we looked at it,
it turned out that it was pasta, bread, potatoes,
fruit juices, they had one pound a day of this.
But yet everybody was blaming something else.
I think that it's much harder to fight
because most of these things are perfectly fine for you
until you have one pound a day or two pounds a day of it.
So now it becomes a problem.
So then the company that sells bread or pasta
or potatoes say you're crazy,
there's nothing wrong with potatoes.
I agree.
But yeah, you now have 10% extra every day.
That's all you need, not even 2%.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
An extra 50 calories a day
and if you look at the last 40 years,
that's all that has increased, calorie intake
it's not about protein.
When we had the low fat period, people gain weight,
we had the low carb period, people gain weight.
But we now have hundreds of calories more than 50 years ago
that we take in per day and that's what does the trick,
and of course the composition also matters.
So if you have red meat, et cetera, et cetera.
Now we know that as I just mentioned
from these meta-analysis.
So it's not just about the calories,
but certainly the calories are a good place to start.
I do think the pasta in Italy is different though,
when you eat it there,
I feel fine after eating it there
whereas when I eat it here,
I feel lethargic and tired after eating it.
I don't know if the flour is different or what's going on.
Like do you have a sense of that,
or is it just, I'm having a romantic experience
being in Italy.
No, I'm gonna make the minister of agriculture very happy
by saying, buy Italian pasta,
it's available in the United States.
And so we didn't set up to advertise for anybody,
but maybe.
It is possible that there are, certainly different pastas
have been made in different ways
and with different gluten levels, with different grains.
And I think the best one is probably
the one that with the whole grains.
Much lower gluten,
that's what we used to use back in the days,
70 or 80 years ago, and those are probably preferable,
but most of the pastas out there are high gluten
and they're not using these whole grains.
Not anymore.
Well, I think a good way to kind of end this
is with a few thoughts for the person
who's new to all of this and is thinking,
wow, this is some great information.
I'm excited about this. I want to try an FMD.
I should get my blood work done, figure out where I'm at.
Like, what is like a good on ramp for the uninitiated
to begin to start thinking about food, diet, lifestyle,
longevity?
Probably get my book.
I don't make a penny out of it.
It's all going to the-
That's right, you give all the money to-
100% of the funds go to charity or to the foundation.
And I think the book is pretty extensively explaining
everything we talked about.
I don't think I have anything that I would like to change
other than maybe emphasize more the personalization.
I don't think I did a good enough job in the original book
talking about, if you're gluten sensitive,
if you're sensitive to tomatoes
or you're sensitive to something,
you probably need to avoid some of these things
and find an alternate.
I published it in Italy and now it's coming, the cancer book
We focused on cancer and our nutrition
can make a big impact in fasting mimicking diets,
but also nutrition make a big impact on cancer patients,
both prevention and treatment.
So that's coming in maybe about a year from now, yeah.
Well, I think you're performing an unbelievable service
at a great time of need in terms of health.
So I applaud you, I'm at your service.
I appreciate the work that you do
and I'm excited to see where this science takes us.
I think it feels like we're on the precipice
of some pretty amazing breakthroughs
as the convergence of all these different
research modalities and technologies become more robust
and widely available.
I think we're gonna see some really cool stuff happening.
Yes, yes.
And thank you for doing an amazing job on your side.
I think the information
we could do all the work in the world,
and if it doesn't get out there explained correctly,
it's like Peter Andalaro used to say,
it's like it never existed.
Yeah, well, I appreciate that.
So pick up Valters book, the longevity diet,
and if they wanna learn more about you, your website,
valterlongo.com or where?
I think the foundation, create cures foundation.
And again, there's createcures.org.
There's a clinic that you can visit and yeah.
So createcures.org is probably the best information.
Facebook also, professor Valter Longo English site.
We have lots of articles that we publish
and everybody not just what we do here.
Cool, and enjoy Italy.
Thank you.
Yeah, you go six months, six months.
Six months in Italy, a rough six months of Italian summer.
I'm jealous my friend.
Well, I appreciate talking to you always,
you're always welcome here and enjoy your summer
and stay in touch.
Thanks, Rich.
Sure, peace.
(instrumental music)